I know this came about after a
conversation he had with Eli rostered
net and it's based on a kind of April
Fool prank - so tell us more about both
those things well we made a film called
dead hooker in a trunk and that was a
hugely inspired by the multi
collaborative our grindhouse yeah and so
we contacted every director after we
read on that and one of them was Eli
Roth and he was kind enough to really
help us out and afterwards with that and
he was like what other scripts do you
girls have so we didn't have anything so
we just [ __ ] it Himel as I kind to
us we decided to lie to the man right so
I had this one of that one I have this
one about this medical student he's like
oh that one sounds like a great one I
like to read and really oh [ __ ] well I
just would be so embarrassed if there's
any like spelling mistake so I got
totally so he said just give us like a
two weeks to brush it up and then we're
like [ __ ] we need a script and I turned
her and I was like dude what the [ __ ] do
you know about body modification I knew
enough I knew enough so that's how it
went about but um I was obsessed with
body modification for a long time
because when I first saw it on the
internet it's scared ween I find all
fears are because of a lack of education
on something so the more you learn about
it the less scary does and it turned out
I was really fascinated by how missa
understood the body mod community is
everybody turns them into these monsters
it's a big winch hunt we're dealing with
them but in reality they're very
down-to-earth and really normal so it
was kind of fun to play on people's
stereotypes in the film hopefully got
two female directors here in front to me
very strong female lead in the film as
well how important is that to you guys
it's absolutely vital we started out as
actors and because of our being
identical twins when we're little it was
more like child labor laws that we were
working and then as we got older it was
you know [ __ ] this or hooker that and
I started to have a resume that looks
like I was a vivid girl so we decided to
take a step back we are extensively
trained in martial arts so we thought
maybe we'll do stunts instead and then
maybe we'll be scantily clad but we'll
be doing you know some ass-kicking that
we can be really proud of so then we got
into the whole dead hooker thing and you
kind of still got offered those roles
so it's so important for us to write not
just female parts but male parts that
are you know something that you actually
want to do I found it as a young actor I
was always auditioning for parts that I
didn't really want I just wanted to be
working and we're we are huge fans of
Katherine's since Chandra snaps and I
met her and Josie in the pussycats that
she's really nice to me even though she
doesn't remember that whatsoever she
blocked out being nice to you know what
kept watching her movies and other after
gingersnaps it was like walk on the
[ __ ] girl that and I was like Katy's
so much more talented than that so we
wrote the script with her in mind
because we love Jason we loved Freddy we
loved pinhead but we're like there's no
chicks and you know you must have
noticed and camera dude you must have
noticed this too you know what you know
when you make a chick mad and it gets a
little mater and pissed off like you do
this and she comes back like with this
and really I was like that's an
interesting element of women I was like
what if we had that for our character
and you see a little bit about this
something happens and then she gets uh
she gets a little kiss she gets a little
more than you can I'd sides like for you
it's about on par for a normal human
being it's like oh dude the cops are
coming for you well there's we're like
there's a apparatus that goes into a
gentleman's mouth and that's actually
used for spreading vagina lips and we're
like that's an extra [ __ ] you on top of
it entire thing's gonna be beeped out
because they'd be not necessarily
necessarily tell me about your policy on
blogs they don't fare too well in the
film do they Hitchcock said that the
best victims are blondes it has nothing
to do with us being raven-haired I mean
I just for some reason it happens the
script writes itself inand the blonds
are all [ __ ] dead or mutilated I
don't know just it's my Mac it just
hates blonds I'm like stop very mad I
want them to live well even though we're
a dead hooker in a trunk was a blonde
out of all the characters that are our
four leads come across the dead hookers
or the
living hooker depending on what state of
the movie you come in up is the only
person they actually respect the death
of and you know putting to rest the body
of so we poke fun at it but we try to be
a little kind as well yes I'm talking
about what happens to people in the film
I know there's no CGI is there is some
kind of special but the special effects
of aesthetics it's Todd masters isn't it
tell me more about that it's fascinating
it's been such an honor to work with
Todd masters and masters of facts we
were huge fans of Six Feet Under and
he's done pretty much everything he's
doing True Blood right now among a
billion other projects but we were
looking for someone to do our flescher
it was a pipe dream of ours to work with
masters effects and Todd masters of
course he has a shop in LA in Vancouver
and I I remember us so nervous to talk
to him I had my little notes and it was
like hi mr. masters my name is she wrote
down every conversation now we're really
good friends so we can make fun of it
now and be like hey Todd this is my
first conversation with you because I
was scared [ __ ] to shitless
I remember the first time we said we
need a seven size penis and he
researched that and be like girls he's
not weirded out but he had a box of
penises at my old penises our fake
penises are used a lot in shows
apparently so they had a box of them on
for it was stolen well I don't know why
someone would say the crook is still at
large wherever he is you find a box of
penises in Vancouver that's what masters
yeah quality ones could we expect from
you guys next silence where we're lucky
enough that we have a few opportunities
to do different projects we'd love to do
Bob which is something we were talking
about for a while it's a our final in
our adolescent coming-of-age sort of
trailer trilogy and it's it's starring a
guy maybe he's a touch effeminate I'm
not sure but it's a reverse are on the
rape revenge because there's always
women getting raped for vent so I was
like but that is a common problem in in
the world but you don't really see
anything like that and it has a bit of a
monster movie vibe because easy vampires
you see where well do you see [ __ ]
zombies everywhere but it has
you haven't had an original monster for
a really long time and I guess because
we have such a crush on masters effects
we're like we gotta do a monster movie
but you got to design something special
for us
oh god absolutely stylistically it's
half between American marry and half
between dead hooker in a trunk it's
really hilarious and it's really vulgar
and it's equal of both parts
you